Now that we have covered the main factors of immunology
What I would like to do
In this video, a summary of these factors is worked up
I showed the interaction between these immune factors
That person or person we have been exposed to
B cells, which I always draw in blue
What distinguishes these B cells is
Its walls or membranes associated with antibody antibodies, where
Each B cell whose wall is connected to its modified (assigned)
So this B cell will be so
If you want to draw another B cell here, I will draw
The replaced part is slightly different color
Therefore, different B cells will respond
For different antibodies
Which enters the device
The B cell becomes effective
When linked
The pathogenic factor in the existing receptor
On the wall of the B cell
But this is not the end of the story